je me suis fait accuser demandé des
simulations va faire des gros yeux c'est
paulo puis 6 peut-être que si vous
faites des gros une compagnie de 150
personnes en arrière de vous peut-être
que ça pète intimidant le smartphone
madame la présidente lydie je me
présente paul ney l'eau les 150
personnes comme sur l'homme au chapeau
lors peu poète l'eau quand façonne un
moment crucial est que la personne même
du discours viril et quelqu'un tout seul
avec jeux pour moins de personnes entre
deux mois souvent c'est après ou avant
que les comités de chômage au passé donc
si je comprends bien qu'un vous
intimider quelqu'un vous voulez pas
avoir trop de témoins autour de vous
on sera encore là je vous le dis c'est
l'intimidation à des buts ou pas l'arrêt
tout faire des gros jeux ou banon au
sein de temps au moins le coton on est
on est en construction car vous faites
des gros yeux à quelqu'un poursuit
zebulon fr